off
why so why so uh you don't seem to have
a lot of energy
did it take shrooms did you I don't care
we have to do a podcast
you can't do shrooms I've been working
on my low kicks dude just do it no
because I mean hold on why don't you
have energy you can't how you're an
extremistry
huh you can't take one dude
no adderall it's a roller coaster no
dude no you cannot be
how are we gonna podcast what do you
mean you no you just talk I sit there no
what are you just feel like you really
care about burning you can't overdo [__]
you have to micro dose if you're gonna
do that Frank set them well that doesn't
mean you take a bunch
I'm gonna do the pack
in the pocket here we go
look he's all loose oh leaning to one
side that's it that's good leaning to
one side okay good all right well
podcast here
laughs
look how much [__] they said oh [__]
well you can't take a whole thing too
well they're gummies I know but I
shouldn't told me they're just candy
you're moving slowly
I wonder why you're
hey it's gonna come and it's gonna come
in and out you can't do that before the
show
well that's uh fighting the kid folks
we'll see you later that's awesome
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
Chin's High I went to I want to get your
take on this so I was in Edmonton
uh now Edmonton is oil oil and bears if
you want to hunt bears you go to
Edmonton when you talk to those guys on
the when they work the oil fields by the
way crazy amazing crowds I'm talking
about Grizzlies up there yeah now now a
couple things about me I'm sorry if I
feel if I look a little if I I'm a
little [__] up right now because I
spent three days straight in the mall
because you can't go outside when it's
30 below zero 40 with wind chill ladies
and gentlemen yes well okay yes you're
not going out you can take a cup of
coffee throw in the air it freezes
before it hits the [__] group the one
that's lined up to go to just saying bro
Edmonton love my Edmonton crowds but
February might be maybe wait a little
bit spring fall just depends if you sell
good tickets who cares that's all that's
all that matters but I I walked that I
walked that [__] come on I'm a board
it's got five years of the exact same
thing correct got so bored I went into a
knife shop and talked to the guy about
swords yeah so just fake asking fake
questions about swords there's seven
questions there's seven gaps in that
mall
now the guy has I go can you carry a
sword is that what is the legal right
I'm so bored I go now now you have a
Broad Sword do you have do you get do
you carry samurai swords I'm asking
questions dude I don't know that's what
he was doing he was going yeah I mean I
suppose I mean yeah you can't carry one
right yeah but I mean you know it'd be
nice and I was like yeah how would you
get in cars and you stayed in the hotel
next to that connection that's correct
sir it's called Fantasyland depressing
is it each you think each floor is a
different fantasy yeah but try getting
uh an elevator because the sir there are
no service elevators sir oh yeah oh
there's a lot going on but either way it
smells like Cinnabon yeah and when you
go now now when you go and you work in
the [__] oil fields you will see
wolves and you will see Bears weekly so
if you want to go hunt bear like our boy
Joe did you go out to Edmonton up there
though there's co-workers you got bit in
the head with it by a mosquito the kind
of mosquitoes that live up there Joseph
did yeah got bitter in the forehead he
he looked like um he had the mark of
cane on him oh wow yeah those mosquitoes
are like I'm gonna shoot something that
you haven't seen I'm gonna suck all your
blood out of your forehead
okay I'm gonna pump this juice in your
face just a giant scar uh but that's
what he said yeah and then you uh and
then you you now now when the black
bears show up that's what you shoot if a
Grizzly shows up run you climb a tree
I know
you can climb too though well Grizzlies
apparently not so black bears scoot
right up a tree yeah yeah they'll scoot
black bears are stupid though yeah but
here's the thing about Edmonton it's
very flat it's oil and bears and I
always wonder who was the person that
said follow me and then when they got
there they were like this is home this
is it
do you see the wolves and Grizzlies like
this is it also the wind like I'm
envying I want to be a moose right now
you know that you should not be
somewhere when you envy the animals
there because you're like at least
they're warm and they get to live on
grass you didn't like it huh well I just
wouldn't you couldn't live there I got
on the summer it was amazing settle
there in the summer it's amazing yes but
if you're a Native American if you were
the Nate First Nation people there and
then the white man was like look we're
gonna take your lamb but we'll trade you
a huge Mall in diabetes how's that sound
yeah yeah go to Florida you're an Indian
just hitchhike to Florida
yeah right I I follow the birds South
you and I I would delete the leaders
like a little further and he was like
this is it I would kill him with a knife
I would kill I'd just keep going I won't
even tell him and then I and then I
followed the birds South uh anywhere
that's warmer I would just go I'll be
right back I'm taking piss and then just
keep going and then just assume we got
to eat and ass first by black bears yeah
but really we're getting tanned now now
tipping hooking up with them navajos
heavy on the hoe
I never thought of that dude what's up
bro now now in that cold you understand
what you do you gots to be with your
dogs and your guts to be with your
caribou and your boys and your boys
because you're living on your caribou
and you're living on your dogs are
keeping you safe from all the Bears your
boys keeping you warm that's right
what right now you got your ladies too
well how about how about this guy he uh
climbed like he did some you know this
guy I'm gonna climb eight peaks in
[__] a week yeah sure
he was in the North Pole or the South
Pole wherever it was if you think it's a
real place yeah and they're walking and
they're like they're it's like they're
exhausted they're they're pulling their
own sled because he's into these
endurance exhibitions like we we pulled
a sled over the North Pole the South
Pole that's what I was dead and he's
like he's like his face is you know the
wind and he's [__] like they're
starving and yeah of course white guy
and they're they're he and his partner
and and like he's a pretty famous
mountain climber and so they're like
famous as they get yes yeah in the
mountain climbing circles right sir in
the mountain in the Alpine Circle sir
very famous as he's pulling the thing
he kind of feels a thing turns around
two polar bears right behind him
stalking him nothing worse nothing worse
most aggressive bear in the market
correct correct
and uh that story ends oh no with them
getting eaten ass first no let's just
pretend that happened no because the
story's going nowhere right because the
beer's got nothing then the Bears
because and also it's not yourself it's
not your fault right that guy's lying
and now you got to carry this [__]
torch so but we're gonna make this
towards much more fire so he turns
around
the bear comes at him
he pulls his six shooter out he carried
six two six shooters yes right remember
yep yep and he goes he says to his buddy
he goes get down and his buddy goes no
and his buddy runs and throws himself on
the grenade so to speak on the white
grenade the big hairy one and then the
guy shoots his friend Goose goose and
his friend dies but then the other Bears
they eat his friend and then he was able
to get away and he got away he didn't
have to kill the Bears because that's a
better story they're endangered and now
the next person can tear that [__]
torch see that's right so that's
congrats dudes
Edmonton was cold huh Edmonton I was
here in L.A now La is no punk either we
had yeah you know some flurries bro the
rain yeah hey chill the [__] and I don't
want to hear people complain about you
know shortages of water we got all the
water got a lot of water I've never seen
anything like it yeah when I gotta feel
our fires up dude I I did a show I
worked in Burbank Thursday night it was
raining so hard Jason I mean Jay shop
driving down there Jay's like I've never
seen rain like this coming back
snow
Abby Kenny snow everywhere what I didn't
sign up for this really I left Colorado
not to deal with the snow correct I'm in
my car I've never heard the sign go
because ding below 37 degrees I'm like
below 37. what the [__] is that all the
trucks pulled off on the highway yeah
yeah they all the trucks were pulled off
from the sideline I think the resting
Jay goes no dumbass there's black ice
everywhere because it was you know when
you're going over the overpass which got
shut down yeah the rain was nuts I
haven't because and then so I worked uh
Bakersfield Thursday night my crowd my
god oh there's a they come out and force
yeah yeah well I signed some tits guy
tips I saw it sold out too right yeah
yeah so but then so then on uh Saturday
did Back The Ice House Is Back open bro
they shut down for three years uh keto
George came they redid it I hear it
looks like uh it's nuts up I hear it's a
laser Factory like just it's like you're
in the movie Tron but doing stand-up it
is not the amount of money they put in
they have a VIP room you should see this
room geez then the exit you'll use the
slide straight to LeBron's house yeah
yeah okay so we'll say that again so
there's a slide that goes right now back
exit yeah oh yeah yeah yeah I was like
oh I'll see you guys are like no no I
went yeah because I woke up what the
[__] are you doing here I'm like I'm
here for the gangbang oh because it used
to be that slide would land you into
just a bunch of marshmallows remember
right now you're in LeBron's house it's
like Space Jam too yeah and then there's
in in the gangbang room yes okay it's
pretty cool either way but the room's
dope the only problem is that you know
they're new the book is so dope I think
your name's Ally I think is that right
something like real uh comedy Aficionado
like rope for comedy for years she's
great but the only it the only they go
any notes I said the only should I have
it was as bright as this room the entire
entire room got it I'm like that's why
there's so much talking because they
don't feel like they're gonna come here
you need to do and then so that room
great dope but tearing that place down
feels like killing an old tree though
there's so much it's time on getting
dude this is how I know I'm getting
older I'm anti-change they change the
sign and I walk you I'm like what are
they doing what are my brother goes are
you 80 years old why would you mess with
a good thing it's the ice house he's
like dude and it's dope sign the new
sign So Dope looks like ice is coming
down yes but then the you're in the the
small room next door where they do like
I did a ton of open mics there they
change that it seats like 90. you should
see this room this cozy little dope room
now but so well done oh wow think of
think of like the belly room but look at
you look at the boys
Adam Ray crushed it that's will Burkett
I don't know if you know him I don't
know any of this will start but he
booked his own tour now he's selling out
everywhere wow and he opens up for me
from time to time monster young kid
monster amazing and then that's Trevor
Wallace he's so [__] he he had a joke
I could not I even text him next morning
he saw him I don't want to give his joke
away but he said he said don't don't
give it it's so [__] funny I was
laughing so [__] hard
and then tall George he's been getting
up a bunch he's been in Stanford two
years yeah so he's been doing I love him
host I didn't know that yeah it's funny
holy [__]
um yeah Trevor's the man yeah it's great
all right let's take a quick break take
a break let's take a little break from a
hilarious story I know dude sorry hey
what are you chewing on
Little Thing Called time all right
Little John Hey listen Chimes you wake
up every morning and check your credit
score every morning okay because I
thought so nobody does that but time
does that for you they are secured chime
credit Builder
they have a secured credit Builder
Builder Visa credit card credit build I
have a Visa card that's actually a
credit Builder okay wow you can start
building your credit with your own money
it reports your payments to credit
bureaus to help you direct uh build
credit over time but they have a ton of
fees be dude no no fees and they're
members see an increase of 30 points on
average no fees no large security
deposits or checks this is credit checks
at all okay so start your credit Journey
with chime sign up takes only two
minutes and doesn't affect your credit
score get start at chime.com that's
c-h-i-m-e.com slash fighter that's
chime.com fighter let me read a
mandatory disclosure the chime credit
Builder Visa credit card is issued by
stride bank and a person of a license
with Visa USA chime checking account and
200 qualifying direct deposit required
to apply for their secured chime credit
Builder Visa credit card regular on time
and payment history can have a positive
impact on your credit score impact to
score May Vary and some users score May
not improve move out of network ATM
withdrawal fees May apply except at
MoneyPass ATMs in a 7-Eleven or all
point or VISA plus Alliance ATM you're
still listening that's chime.com fighter
I like money and sports dude I like
money in sports and you got a big UFC
285 this week and yet Jon Jones coming
back the king is back against Cyril gone
get in on the action with the official
sports betting partner the UFC new
customers can bet just five dollars on a
pre-fight money line and get 150 in
bonus bets if your fighter wins
all DraftKings customers can join the
excitement in the octagon with draftking
same game parlays combine multiple bets
at UFC 285 all right for a shot at an
even bigger payout you could parlay Jon
Jones and uh Beau nickel with chefchenko
there's so many ways to get it done Beau
Nichols the easy bet there and they got
chefchenko's big favorite Jon Jones
although Brian disagrees I think Jon
Jones gets it done parlay all three of
them make Bank bro with DraftKings
download the app use the code fighter
new customers can bet just five dollars
on a pre-fight money line and get 150 in
bonus bets if your fighter wins this
Saturday at DraftKings Sportsbook with
code fighter minimum age eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details DraftKings I had a I had friends
over last night and uh one of our
friends told the story that got me going
a little bit out of nowhere it's very
interesting
I wonder if I should tell it yeah I will
well you're gonna have to now otherwise
this story goes nowhere like your bear
story this story didn't go anywhere but
it was like Brian Mr nowhere cow I think
this is a story though that was I
appreciated she goes with some butter
because I feel like I'm among friends I
go oh wait hold on set the scene for
hold I know where this is going hold on
it's it's it's the sun has dropped right
Sun's drops sir is the wine out the
Wine's out dude okay everyone's and it's
been good for a while baby's asleep
thyron fire is on now begin the story
thank you for sending that thank you for
sending me cozies maybe in your sweats
well nobody's wearing shoes nobody's
wearing shoes
you know what I mean even the ladies are
windshield yeah it's all just it's all
cozy coz because we're gonna watch we're
gonna watch the Jake Paul fight and
we'll get to that and okay well that was
at 11AM okay yeah but you got it
reserved it okay and then we watched
because I was on a plane and then we
watched a movie called Vengeance which
we'll get to what I watch the whale with
Brendan okay do you see Vengeance sir
the Venom movie or nope it's BJ Novak
one of the best movies I've seen oh BJ's
great you will [__] love that you'll
watch the whale there's a reason I will
totally watch the whale but this movie
but vengeance is
so [__] good and Ashton Kutcher is so
[__] good in this and everybody's so
[__] good oh okay back to the game
Sorry so
yeah so it's uh just a bunches wait two
guys two girls uh-huh okay keep going
and then maybe another couple oh three
girls three guys yeah okay ratio at
least one in the room in fact we assume
I'm the way oldest
okay everybody else is very good looking
facts okay okay and what the ladies look
like 30s athletic as [__] uh everybody's
working with a lot of work there's
working with a lot of a lot of stuff
going on a lot of good stuff going on
you understand these are vibrant Young
thirty-somethings successful we're not
talking about plus size models here
we're talking about people who work out
twice a day sir you understand me okay
again I'm the ugliest person in the room
and I'm I'm whiskers I'm whiskers and
wrinkles yeah you're the one you're the
the old wise owl in the corner jacking
off keep going
she goes uh
the one I feel like I'm among friends oh
I'm like sure heck cause we've had a
couple of drinks oh that gets that gets
me going yeah I'll be your friend keep
going oh I'm your friend yeah and they
and and in fact I rushed over with a
with a bottle of Piper heightsick I go
for more bubbly French more bubbly yes
my my wife goes take it easy over there
that's like shut up I'm like what I'm
she we're among friends yeah she's a
friend gotta give her some water but it
was really interesting she goes I had a
dream last night I just feel like
sharing it I was in a bubble bath
there was this it was such a turn on
there was this huge carrot
oh well that's a metaphor for it and I
said I said can you describe how big it
was she goes well it was big but it was
really thick oh dude she's a fool so I
go so I go
she's a [__]
it's so aggressive I literally it's so
aggressive I thought you said she's a
four and I won't why is she a four I was
like what
[Applause]
and I began I just started putting it
in myself oh shoot and I go I go did you
say is it a big black carrot no I didn't
say that
because there are no black carrots
[__] man do you mind I'm so sorry I said
so many questions I know bro I'm just so
hot if I can get through the story keep
going so she's in this bubble bath don't
bite your tongue like that don't go like
this
it's
okay so she's in this bubble bath on top
of the water you know bubble bath with
this
fat carrot so she goes I got in this
bath and I got so turned on because I
was letting this carrot do its work on
me and it was so hot and I and I was
just so turned on and then I thought the
story end there I go I go and then she
got a little embarrassed she goes I'm
among friends I go you're among friends
hey everybody I'm friends can we get
some carrots yeah
hey Derek hello Karen run I know you
hear us she needs carrots so and black
it was a big carrot like like that I go
Jesus Christ there's nothing how do you
get a carrot that big right so now I'm
like this but I'm among friends she got
a little offshore now she keeps saying
amongst friends so she's feeling a
little insecure I realize it's more to
the story oh this carrot gets naughty
oh and I go so so you did that and she
goes I know and then wait what's her guy
doing at this point is he like carrot
he's her guy's he's all her guys used to
stud he's kind of quiet her guy knows
her her guy is just like he's here she
goes her guy is a he's a he's a guy's
guy so her guy's like whatever goes on
goes on oh he's like I also like carrots
yeah now now I should I should preface
this by saying my wife not in any of
that okay and not into what carrots my
wife's conservative woman yeah I like
hair no I'm saying you know but she
doesn't like but their situation like
veggies
everybody likes to care
hey dude stop chewing your tongue I'm so
then so then then so I think the story
is over there's quiet and then she goes
but then it got really crazy I go what
happened she goes I I put it in my butt
I'm not even into that but I was just
working my butt
bubble bath and I was like
I was like nothing wrong with that she
goes I'm among again I am among friends
I swear to God forever no I'm your but
we're best friends I said I love you and
I go but I'm I'm I'm rock hard this is
gonna go on my podcast yeah this is
going on my podcast and call her a [__]
it was so funny and then I go like this
I go you honey I go whatever you're
doing now I like whatever you're doing
you're working out you look fantastic
which she did she she works yeah sure
and my wife goes hey hey hey she'll need
that hey back it off yeah and so no
question and then you just watch the
fight but I went I went you should have
lied again you should have finished that
story with and we didn't watch the fight
we had our own fight right well you know
there's always that energy in the room
sometimes so you have friends who are
couples and maybe you know what she was
doing yeah she's like this right now
that in that horror pool yeah
don't don't say horror that's her some
people some people dip their toe in the
swinger pool now we're not swingers me
and my lady she was barking up the wrong
tree but that's okay it's all good I
like the effort but I appreciate the
effort oh what an effort and I really do
appreciate it couples that that that
event get have you ever had do you know
couples that are yeah don't tell anybody
properly but there are apps there are
apps for swinger couples yeah it's not
just like swingers I have never I don't
believe I've ever had a serious
relationship with any woman in my life
that was ever remotely into that no no
you you need frowned you neither yeah
frowned upon but let me ask you this is
it because I like raised that way or is
it because they the judgmental Society
is that what it is and if it wasn't
judgment somebody in the room is going
to get on a podcast and tell this story
well if it wasn't judgmental do you
think women would be more that way I
don't think so no
it'd be a real open flower
yeah you know maybe before kids when you
have kids you're just so [__] can't
be with your mom having your kids in
your ass what are we doing you know what
your mother when you're a mom it all put
this big thick black hair in your ass
it's for the stew baby black carrot why
because no you can get black kids you
never say anything about a black carrot
I picture this is my story though I know
but they're only black orange carrot
orange no that's not fun no it's a it's
like a dark purple carrot they exist
what oh yeah I've had them
black carrot episode bro chin you
brought that up right there an
incredibly nutritious they have high
amounts of
and the signans a pigment that gives a
vegetable a deep purple color that looks
almost black deeper purple Winters in
India are incomplete with it with
various carrot preparations black
carrots are used to make Kali kajar Ki
kanji and stick up your ass drink no one
said that I never had no you told me she
started carrying her look in her dream I
just thought that was a great way
the carrots
them curds first of all apologize to
everybody who listens I'm 56 and I'm I
want to apologize I turned 40 next month
it's so unbelievable that I still
haven't dude people putting carrots in
their ass will never not be fun and more
power too or better but I never I
appreciate the honest I pictured myself
this way because a lot of guys my age
are talking about physics and the world
and and they're serious not for you my
man and I'm just doing this we're
talking about carrots and asses it's not
both changing the world really not
acceptable and udem characters on the
right
yeah well people people have weirdos so
so the comments you did your wife go
okay fight's on like enough's enough
okay fight has started Amy enough with
your [__] I'm gonna tell this story
because it's okay are you feeling
naughty my mother had a friend and she
told me her friends now probably 80
maybe not even around yeah she's
probably Dead uh her she had a friend
who went to see a therapist
and the reason she saw a therapist was
because she could not she was so
obsessed with getting gang banged oh yes
gang banged by construction workers
listen to this that she was [__]
hiring men
work around her house on fake [__]
and then wearing like when she couldn't
help herself and she was
I guess hooking up with hook it up you
could never get all of them idea that
one guy was there and the other guys
were in the room so you guys have to
[__] other guys like
we're working here yes Washington just
banged out yeah it's fake construct I'm
sure she could find something just
because it was uh wait is she older
though if she's your mom
well I don't know how old she was I
don't know how old she was when I was
going on but she was clearly definitely
a [__] a housewife
well my buddy used to put pools in he
was like a good looking guy he would do
I mean you had this he would he would go
to a house and he was out
he would build a pool or he would he
would do maintenance on pools and there
was always because he was a stud there
was always a house a house a housewife
he said he said he'd be down the pool
and they'd come out in a skirt with no
underwear no they just come out on the
skirt with no underwear or whatever and
I was like I remember I go digit and he
goes well of course oh wow I have a pool
guy
he's probably at the house right now oh
[__] no he looks like [__] does by
Design
yeah that pull yeah that [__] is true if
you're gone all the time oh you got a
handsome pool boy I mean
you know you know no my pool guy looks
like trash yeah he looks like an
armadillo yeah oh yeah yeah
boy you came in sexual today I came in I
just started thinking about the stories
daddy what are you trying to do man I
know
I'm not really good carrots the same to
that girl I just love it how complicated
human beings are sexually I like how
open that lady was at the [__] house
party
thank you for sharing that story with me
but never do it again I will never judge
you but I will talk about it on my
podcast oh I'm into it you tell her I
said hey oh yeah 100 percent
she's a great person anyway but yeah
sure I mean you don't know her but also
conservative like like the other what I
like is when somebody walks around and
they're conservative you know what
sounds like she had a little too much to
drink feeling naughty that's what sick
carrot on your table and was like oh
that reminds me yeah I put that in my
ass oh dude my buddy in [__] College
another stud
his dad had a company his dad's second
in command
his wife the guy's wife was 40. my buddy
was 19. and he was changing he had been
in they were on vacation and he's super
muscular and she got drunk and came in
to the room when he was getting changed
and sucked him that's right that's right
why I'm sorry why because he was a stud
and her husband was well he'd let
himself go he had his husband didn't
care he cared but I just didn't know he
didn't know and she kept going you're my
fantasy or my fantasy these [__] dude
Jesus
you want to suck you want to happen to
be tired of you know you're just the
these stats on the husband really
it's on everybody you want to hired the
[__] hot pool boy what you think was
going to happen yeah he had these black
carrots everywhere uh-huh right oh hot
boy he came in hot today man can I get
some color on the fight were you
surprised oh heavy on the color uh oh by
the way speaking of color
I'll be in Nashville this weekend I
don't know if you knew that yeah this
weekend
um well I'm headed to Brea I have one
show Friday because Saturday I have a
fight campaign I have Will Compton from
busting with the Bros awesome I have
jelly roll biggest song right now in
country music wow and Rampage Jackson
for the Return of the King that's a hell
of a fight UFC 285 Jon Jones is
happening this [__] Saturday we
haven't bet on that
don't we did we bet on Rogan uh maybe we
should probably better we can bet on it
we'll bring you down on this but Brea
two shows one night only Friday in
Oklahoma City March 9th through the 11th
then I end March in Tacoma March 23rd
through 25th but you're gonna be in
Nashville yes thoughts on the thoughts
on the uh this this fight breakdown
brought to you by our days okay this
this fight right breakdown is brought to
you by black carrots buy black carrots
in the hot tub
um I mean Tommy uh the the advancement
that he's made because his last fight
like we had Ryan garcian he was a singer
to a box and he goes his first round he
goes wow time's gotten a lot better
because if you watch this last fight he
was I predicted Jake was a knock him out
too with you he goes he's gotten so much
better I said that's what that's what's
tough on predicting fights where a guy
has six fights the other had seven
fights the advancement they make who
knows like you're basing off what you
know so you're based off I'm biased I'm
you know the Paul brothers are my boys I
don't know Tommy but if you look at
Tommy's last fight he didn't he didn't
look anything like this he looked
phenomenal he looked good well uppercut
was there all night I know I thought it
was very easy to score I thought Tommy
won at least yeah I agree five to six
rounds I agree yeah but also like I I
thought to myself he's got about the
best Camp you could get or certainly
I've never worried about that I mean
Jacob's good camp too no never I don't
give a [__] you think his campaign
nearly as good as I don't care about
camps but my whole thing was just
I just Tommy's never been a main event
he's never gone past five rounds he's
never been in a big situation how's he
going to handle the pressure we don't
know Jake's hasn't fought a traditional
boxer yeah Tommy's and a young guy
Tommy's been boxing and a young guy
strong guy so there's all these act
factors so he had a decision it's all
good I thought to myself those guys are
going to watch Jake and they're going to
see what his Tendencies are and they're
gonna they're gonna give him a game plan
that he can follow that's kind of what I
thought he looked really good you look
great avoid the right hand and then I
thought you were susceptible with a left
hook all night he kept getting hit with
the left yes yeah but I thought to
myself a little sloppy fight but they
have seven fights
it was sloppy but I was about to say
like like
boxing's really [__] hard and you're
supposed to look like everything's seven
yeah after seven times like that's he's
been boxing Jake's been boxing what
three years there he is that's you look
like he got it that doesn't fights yeah
some fight yeah and and some fights in
three years isn't a lot
20 years is not a long like just like
you make fun of me but I really did work
hard at boxing in terms of like enough
to know how hard it is and how like just
how it's there's something about the
speed and the margin for error and if
you haven't been doing it forever and if
you start even though he started you
know he still started fairly late
compared to a lot of guys he's young
though and he's athletic so he can make
up that with his training but I just
thought I was watching him and some I
was like man boxing's hard that that's
exact that makes sense but they need
each other like before the fight me and
uh Howie Mandel I was like loser goes
home like losers career is over like if
except for I don't agree on that one
well no hold on hear me out yeah so if
Jake were the Flatline Tommy his
career's over yeah if Tommy flatlined
Jake Jake get your bags you're out
decision all right we can do this again
because you know as Jake said you know
uh Judge Me by my losses now we're gonna
find out if Jake actually wants to be a
boxer that's right because he can make
money doing anything they're coming off
a loss like the losses [__] suck all
right so now let's see what he's made of
now if you actually want to do it get
better go back in the gym he should have
posted a video today him doing road work
or training or something to prove that
he wants this as bad as we think he does
because everyone's saying it's just a
cash grab no proof is wrong so now we'll
see how much he wants to be a boxer
based on his next fight but Tom don't
get twisted Tom only has what eight or
nine fights yep Tommy ain't fighting
another legit box or with who's
undefeated with nine fives they need
each other so there's gonna be a rematch
or there's Logan Paul there there's Nate
Diaz Conor down the road but they need
each other Yep they're because they're
in the boxing Lane but then the fast
lane entertainment Lane you don't want
to get out
no just keep making 20 million dollars
fighting each other you could see that
you could and [__] the haters just keep
making money with Jake you could see he
needs a lot more time it's because they
both could because look I'm sorry but
like stand up because like stand up
there are certain things that I don't
give up explain who you are takes
forever and so you know he doesn't want
to get in there with like a guy who's
had you know some of these boxes no no
no like a real top guy very bad and they
were going to rank if Jake won they're
gonna rank in the top 15. okay well if
you're gonna write them top 15 he's
gonna fight 14 13 12. he's gonna fight
the 16 17 guys are no joke no they're
monsters yeah but that that's what
that's where I get the lines get blurred
like don't get it twisted like yeah he's
good for only having six or seven fights
so is Tommy they're both flawed as [__]
and have a long ways to go I hate to
tell you neither One's Gonna Be World
Champs no Tommy doesn't have a long
career in this they need each other yes
so they should rematch or fight at Logan
but stay in that lane and make the money
don't jump over it I was like is this do
you really want to do this like I think
I'm really excited about to find out I'm
excited about the rematch but I thought
to myself like what's the upside of
actually trying to go for it as a boxer
well what's go for it means guys let's
go for it mean like go for it doesn't
get an actual rank boxer where you're
fighting real ranked guys
I think the go for it for him is is
Tommy beat Nate then for hopefully it
Conor fight your brother and you four or
five fights and get out of it exactly
like if your goal is to fight like a
Canelo no no no and he says that
sometimes but I'm like he's trolling but
he knows let me ask you this do you
think that because he's famous and
because he's
um no does he in the in his Camp when he
has uh sparring partners do you think
the sparring partners go easier no no no
they don't know this is stupid no no he
wouldn't make it this far he Drake
trains hard as [__] I know he transfers
with sparring what kind of what kind
what would you what do you bring I love
her guys who are moving around with him
yes that are similar they're no no no no
no they're trying to knock him out no no
he goes all out his sparring's insane
his sparring I think is too hard like
they they go balls out yes because he's
with and that's the boxing Community
like training is sparring nobody takes
it easy B in boxing that's not what they
do the sweet science they [__] they [__]
each other up yeah Jake's in that world
you know and his coaches are straight
legit world-class boxing coaches yeah
they're giving him the works damn but
you know again it takes time it takes
time I think for both I think he's as
good as it gets for that much three
years he's done even Ryan Garcia said
this he goes people want to make fun of
he's fighting MMA guys he's fighting
hard competitions than I thought in my
first six fights oh yeah and Floyd
Canelo he goes he's like for him to be
only six fights in fighting these type
of guys he's just really tough yes and
that's Ryan Garcia he's fighting Javonte
Davis next has did you talk to him about
that oh yeah can you imagine if I was
like nah didn't bring it up dude what
that's going to be April 22nd
and obviously Tank's favorite yeah he's
almost three to one favorite
that's got to be I got my boy Ryan man
that's gotta be nerve-wracking not to
him he didn't give a [__] he was like
I'm not nervous about all we we've been
asking for this fight for a reason yeah
monster
he lives around here great kid great
[__] I heard and I heard he was
really good on the show it's fantastic
yeah he's great how tall I don't know
man it's my height no
shorter thinner five ten-ish I think
better five ten
I don't care
black I have them but they're in my
pants right now oh my God I'm wearing if
you know what I mean yeah you missed a
good time on the companion buddy and
we'll miss you this Saturday too because
you'll be in Nashville but I do how
about just for Jon Jones return which we
can get to just for Jon Jones return I
told Justin I said I'm like yeah you
have to cancel Bray on Saturday it's
like what like I have to do a companion
for Jon Jones return I have to you have
to I never canceled like I have to dude
and you canceled yeah yeah I'm only
doing two shows on Friday I was supposed
to do Friday Saturday look you get in
accidents in life you get into car
accidents over five million car crashes
000 a day 600 an hour yes they're a
shocking number of them I've been in an
accident you scared an accident you get
injured and you're out of work and
you're in big trouble guess what Morgan
Morgan is an injury Law Firm that can
make you whole you can file a claim from
your couch in eight steps you're not
suing the person the insurance company
you don't need a ton of money to hire a
lawyer either Morgan Morgan's America's
largest injury Law Firm they have over
100 offices Nationwide and more than 800
lawyers with over 15 billion dollars
recovered for their it's also free
submitting an insurance claim with
Morgan Morgan is so easy and it's free
okay
they win yeah man yeah it's so easy it's
more like supporting take out than
hiring a lawyer they make it super easy
for you guys if you're ever injured in
an accident you can check out Morgan and
Morgan their fee is free unless they win
for more information go to
forthepeople.com fighter or dial pound
law that's pound529 from your cell phone
that's forthepeople.com fighter f o r
the people.com fighter or pound law
pound 529 from your cell this is a paid
advertisement can you can I see uh can
you hold card dude you're going to want
to get your character we put some money
down too
most people think she lost her last
fight but yeah and then my boy Bo
Nichols is fighting too he kicks off the
main event I mean sorry so do you want
to get into this
I mean uh you you you have you have uh
Jon Jones John under I mean the safe
bets under four via submission or TKO
from elbows wow really any other brain
Busters uh I got zero gone sure yeah you
think the layoffs there's too much for
John he's too slow I just think that
you're talking about a very big man in
cereal gone a high level Striker I have
to believe he's been working every angle
he's in France so he's close enough to
those Eastern European places where he's
probably bringing people in who are
going to show him a whole bunch of looks
clinches and all that learning how to
stop the takedown
um do me a favor Brian tell me the best
wrestler Cheryl guns beat I'll give you
some time Chingo and bring his record up
well you have any kids well I'm gonna go
ahead and say show me the best wrestler
though what's the best crap ladies fight
in the UFC I would say he's not fought
any Grapplers no but just name the best
one out of there bye junior DeSantis oh
so who didn't attempt to take down uh
but I'll tell you who out grappled them
with one leg I know Francis and God
[Music]
how much you want to bet
I'll bet you uh I'm gonna go I'm gonna
go I'm gonna go two grand on this go
heavy Daddy go heavy I'll bet you five
carrots you want to go five grand uh
but what are you saying now you're
saying no no this one you said no I
think he finished them do you want to do
that
he's a slight favorite uh let's put a
grant five five Jesus is a lot because
when I wish the UFC they posted John Hen
mitts wasn't great now who knows maybe
he still looks a little slow that little
plotting that's a lot of weight to put
on
remember he doesn't knock guys out he
doesn't need to he finishes them
you're relying on his wrestling here he
gets hit too I'm relying on everything
you cannot get hit by Cyril gone nope
not at all so so uh I'm gonna have to go
back to Cyril's record though Jane this
is the other confusion people want to
make
Cyril's not really a knockout artist
knocked out tied to a boss well you have
to busy oh no you have to yeah tied to a
boxer but that's where I went oof type
two of us is full set he has no Derek so
again full sent Derek Lewis has no
chance yeah all right an older Junior
him behind me yeah that's fine yeah so
so decision to Tanner Bowser right uh
decision to rosenstruke right decision
to Alexander volkov right yep he's not
really a knockout artist yeah he'll pick
you apart yeah now you can Derek Lewis
tied to avasa some of you knocked out
when you fight those guys unless it's
Francis Derek but other than that
slugging away I I I those guys go For
Broke and he's a high level kickboxer
yeah this ain't a kickboxing match yeah
you're crazy if you think John's gonna
his ego's so big he's been like yeah I'm
just gonna sit on that take into account
one ring into account ring Russ the drug
is the fact that he could he can make
205 and you can never make 205. and
either could Cyril gone that's a that's
significant it's just John can't make
205 now in 205 he said kill his body I'm
sure he did but his Camp still Jonas his
camps were just same cutting weight
really yeah so talented he is because
there's 205 is too big of a cut he hated
cutting weight yeah he'd walk around
240. he doesn't have a reach advantage
that here does he yes he does he does
yep how much get him out
let's see and he knows how to use it he
has the longest reach in the UFC tied
with Stephan Johnson 85-ish right so
serogon's 81. damn no John was I think
it's 82. I think it's 85-ish let's see
might be 84. I think John's 84. 84.5
Jesus Christ man any other brain Busters
God damn yeah but no you put you got two
grand on Sir gone
straight up I'm not doing any of this
carrot [__] yeah
I just think that um John's going to be
slower sure I didn't need my gas oh yeah
I think he's got it because he's got so
many times before he's got ring rust and
I think he just can't I think he's going
to get pieced up
I don't think he can
he's definitely sparring with
heavyweights yeah and always
Molly [__] them
Brendan said that training with him no I
mean he's a freak he said he wouldn't
mess up you don't want to bet against a
champion like you just it's a dumb idea
but I'm going to just I'm going to
because I was so impressed with Cyril
gone with tied to avasa and that's what
sold you he's just so big he's just
physically his frame is bigger and
that's significant and I and I think
John's scratched up right well and hey
hey friends don't right questions well
hey
guys
get down on the sickness dude I'm just
saying that he you got two grand
he's just a giant man now bring up the
Godsmack logo
he's a freak too athlete he is now real
quick now we're very bad so I'm not
trying to change your mind you know John
has more title defenses same same job no
John has more title defenses than Cyril
Gone John is the goat so remember and
saragon has never faced never a Grappler
now not only is he facing a Grappler
he's facing the best to ever do it the
guy took down Daniel took down a
two-time Olympian Daniel Cormier broke
him yeah you'll see that picture
Daniel's face like oh [__] yeah yeah
dude yeah now to to advocate for your
side based off his last three fights he
used No Rest correct and got hit all the
time yes and some people thought he lost
time graves in Thiago Santos that's my
thing but you're banking on that you're
banking on that one who didn't give a
[__] shown up to this one when this is
for history and cement his legacy is the
brown Gris of all time and you [__] up
I know you [__] up right you don't
want to bet against the champion but you
just did all right there you go
oh man my eyes itching don't put your
eye gunk on my hand are we about a two
grand and a bag of black carrots yeah
dude I want chickens at the same time
see that because when I've poisoned you
I watch you die oh yeah there you go
that I can't that fights that card
stacked dude can I see who else is
fighting yeah because we got see if you
recognize any of those things we got
shishenko
who's the last person Alexa Gras so far
it doesn't matter you won't know but
listen I don't know if you look at the
rest of the card just look at the rest
of the card B let's not get going on the
Alexa Grasso rabbit one right I don't
know shot oh Cat Daddy they think he's
gonna be the next welterweight champ
undefeated Savage beat Neil magni oh
[__] that guy's a killer that's all I
think you know what I'm talking about
um gam rot right he fought deruge Savage
Jalen Turner that's probably Friday
night then Beau Nichols gonna twist
Jamie pick his dick off yeah Bo nickel
oh that's my guy dude
yeah the entire I watched United States
is banking on him yeah he's a killer oh
and look at the prelims Cody garbrand
[__] Derek Brunson duplicity's great
fight uh Ian Gary's fighting the early
prelims Jessica Penny it's it's a great
[__] car take all my money take my
money Brian what can you can I get your
picks
Jones shevchenko
uh cat rat daddy uh gamrat bo nickel
Cody garbrandt Derek Brunson Julian
Marquez in game Cody garbrandt really
yes he's had a he's had a rough one of
uh he's had a rough go for a while he's
my friend
holy [__] my eyes itchy now can uh can
uh can psoriasis get in your eyes I
think it's mushrooms bro let's make my
eyes itch
because what happens is you just fix it
on something and you go hmm mine's
itching huh none of my other body's
itching though how do you feel though do
you feel good I feel all right man
um
no I want to know all I can think about
is big black hair
you'll fix it on one thing no I'm all
you've been thinking about it no no no
all right good
well um oh you gotta watch that movie
The Whale Brennan Fraser is only a three
million dollar budget it's made like
whatever 30 million locations he's
supposed to win the Oscar oh it's good
really the heartfelt
uh Vengeance one of the best movies I've
seen in a long time modern day uh modern
day you gotta watch the whale though
it's gonna win all the ones how did he
do that was that just all that CCI no
fat suit damn he was in the chair for
like eight hours they said [__]
I'm slowly turning into that he's the
nicest guy in the world oh look at him
oh man is it really sad it is sad it's a
hard it's a good movie what a picture
you saw it no I just I lived it yeah
it's a good movie
you don't have a daughter and you're not
gay spoiler you didn't you did live it
yeah besides have you seen it no you
should watch it though I want to get
your take his stories your story is
definitely anything different than his
yeah
my home I'll tell you that that movie of
pulling the heartstrings and then
[__] American Idol dude they had this
[__] kid on there he was a mass mass
shooting a school shooting lost eight of
his friends he's in the same room he
goes I never had Compass at the same
kind of a bigger kid with a mullet and
he starts singing this country he sings
Whiskey Myers and dude and uh uh Katy
Perry just starts crying she's like in
tears and you've never seen this
emotional she's like America has failed
you she goes you should be here to sing
because you want to sing not because
you're you're scared from a mass [__]
shooting great mullet though but he
makes it then they dude it pulls out
your heartstrings then this uh other
little talented girl she's 15. her dad
is the military
and I forget she grew up in some small
town but she wanted to go to New York to
get voicing and lessons then dad's like
the only way I can do that I enter the
military but I'm gonna be gone all the
time but I'll sacrifice for you so her
dad's missed all nine of her birthdays
never around they bring her in she can
see they give her the Platinum tickets
that they have one platinum in every
city where you just skip the first round
she can hey shout out to Dad dude check
this out they go we have a video from
your dad I'll get you oh so the dad's
like love you babe blah blah
they go we have one more gift so so
they're like you know she blows the roof
off the [__] place they go and then
her dad just walks in behind oh what can
I see this please yeah we get kicked off
here you gotta watch it on Sunday nights
yeah is her name Caitlyn Hedges she's
only one 15 year old on American Idol
this year with a military Dad yeah there
it is military dad surprise 50 year old
daughter
okay
do you want to watch it yeah and then
cut it out yeah sure it's as good a show
as a guess it's my favorite I cried yeah
they don't know is it he has another
family overseas and that's and and and
she was at your house talking about
carrots
chin bring up the school shooter Kid
last one
I'm this show every Sunday I cry every
[__] Sunday Jesus Christ
crazy I can't I came to watch your show
he's Texas I can't believe you don't
watch the show but he's Texas too he's
like he's just like [__] tough he's
just like yes ma'am yeah yeah like
proper I've been through it
sells mattresses
Angel sing my ass off things like that
I'm buying a [__] mattress from him
I'm going to dance yeah am I getting a
little carried away a little bit dude
you've never seen that show dude nuts
nuts [__] hard not to cry nuts dude oh
every I mean my girl every Sunday cry
I cry hard bro
well if you don't cry over that when you
have kids too oh it makes you so oh way
worse yeah
once they get into the like real rounds
I don't like it yeah I like now
the come up is one of the auditions what
I like once they start doing like Disney
weekend [__] I'm out but right now like
when they're coming up and you hear the
stories oh I love it they got away from
me really used to like show like how bad
people are and the judges would be like
super brutal they got completely away
from them good which yeah I remember
that I don't like it I didn't like it
either no I don't like making fun of me
I'm like Inspirations I don't like now
I'm I'm not with you on that oh really I
don't think there shouldn't be a whole
show on making fun of people but you
just I like getting people chin Chat
Show Business is the most ruthless
business in the world some of these
people because they have a sad story
you're going to Hollywood I'm like
you're doing a disservice you need to
move on with their life in the beginning
though they would have people that you
knew or not right in the head and then
they would just make make fun of them
they'd show up dressed in a certain way
and then they just fun though yeah and
that's all they wanted was their air
time but then we make fun they're like
this isn't for you man people are
looking for real competition but now now
everything's like I'm you know me I'm
the most positive person I don't [__]
with the negativity but when someone's
like you can tell they're not on the
they're not you see the talent like that
15 year old and then him yeah and then
they'll pass them because whatever they
have some sad story they're like well
you're going to Hollywood's like no dude
oh how these people are gonna get kicked
in the [__] nuts when they get to
Hollywood yeah it's such a you think
Sports is Savage yeah come to Hollywood
oh my God what and by the way I'll add
something else you can be an amazing
actor you can be an amazing talent and
you don't ever get seen never there are
plenty I've spent enough time in acting
class where I saw some just I mean
[__] genius actors and they're still
working at a restaurant
selling mattresses
my my acting teacher used to say that
he'd look at them and go you're the most
talented person in this class and I'll
throw you the [__] out of here
and I remember this one guy goes I've
learned so much from you he goes I don't
care I don't care the fact that you're
not working means you've got to focus on
something else but you're the best actor
I've ever I've seen in this class he
said something's just not connecting
like couldn't never got a shot yeah it
came from a wealthy family oh no no and
he picked up on it he goes you come from
money huh yeah somebody goes a lot is a
plan B
huh he if there's a plan B if you have
like a a fault Plan B because there's
somebody starving out there desperation
is not a bad thing man you know
yeah if it works out for you you know
yeah well I mean yeah yeah but but
hunger Hunger let's put it that way
hunger Drive yeah
I get you don't watch that show either
Jen American Idol yeah I used to watch
it way back in the day oh it's good I
don't have regular TV now I just okay
but what did you think uh that girl that
girl's voice what'd you think at 15
years old insane dude right that young
all the range and stuff the school
shooting kid a little Rocky and it's
good you probably won't win it but he's
you should be in his personality
nowadays you don't need to be the best
singer just you have to you have to be
someone that actually stands out he
probably doesn't have as much time to
work on it and stuff he's just got a lot
of instinct but I could tell there's a
big difference and that girl's
instrument that girls that 15 year old
she's training yeah that's why Katie
would they were saying this on the show
last night she's like we have so much
like raw talent because it'd be the
first time they've ever sung in public
yeah like most and like she was when I
was coming up everyone would do shows
open mics yeah now you're like have you
been on stage like nope never like the
first time ever singing out louds here
in front of us like yeah she goes which
is on it's not supposed to work like yes
but yeah so what's happening now is all
these kids are they're watching exactly
that's one of the best yes and so and
this is even happening in like tennis
you've got kids that are that have grown
up watching Roger Federer their Strokes
are exactly like that then the rest is
just how big and strong are you but
[__] everything is just tuned up
advances and yeah and so these so now in
Juilliard like Juilliard was like the
place where Robin Williams won it was
always really it was the most
prestigious where you learn how to dance
all that yes but now the person who was
auditioning said everybody who steps in
there is [__] uh working on a level
that 10 15 years ago we would have been
like oh my God they're all like one
whole bunch yeah they're all like that
they're all just singing on a diff you
hear these people it's like but also
American Idol too you have to back in
the day like the first 15 seasons are on
season 21 now first 15 Seasons you have
to fly in the city where they're holding
auditions they don't do that anymore
really now you submit a video so they
they're getting people from Ghana from
India that fly in they go yep you're
come in because you pass them from L.A
that's why you're not getting them crazy
well that's why you're not doing crazy
oh Child Things Are Gonna Get Easier uh
dude my tone dude oh Child Things Are
Gonna Get Easier I don't mind it dude I
think I think the limits
I think it's 15 to four literally I'm
too old it was younger it's like 15 to
maybe 30 maybe 35 is the limit things
are gone I get easy uh 29. oh man no
more than one really God damn it
yeah I remember hearing me hit that note
I know it's just the boats sailed
America
doesn't matter the boat sailed 23 years
ago for you Mama
I know somebody's gonna hear that
Broadway they're gonna hear that
didn't mean to make you cry
if I'm not back again this time tomorrow
carry on watch this carry on this is the
ship sale dude carry on Carrie oh more
of a Broadway Vibe really any more
carrot stories
let's end this [__] right now current
events current events
um this okay this was from we didn't use
this yet this is from last week but
there was right now alligator alligator
[__] man also hey [__] you live in
Florida what you doing walking by a pond
not a bad way to go though but why they
gotta do that Gator like that why they
gotta they got his hands behind his back
it's not like his shoulders are like
cars beginners like [__] it's like that
Gator oh man the kid is like are you
[__] me some old lady comes by and I
eat her you [__] tie me up like a
prisoner so the the gator went for the
her dog first and then she tried to save
the dog and the gator dragged her into
the water said even better and she's 85.
she was 85. she says oh he said I like
my meat aged right yeah
that's aged 80 years wagyu white girl
knuckle 85 85 years wagyu not a bad way
to die that's it not a good way probably
hey that's the worst way to time dude
they don't kill the galley is they her
fragile bones when he did the gator roll
yeah
everybody grabbed her like so this guy
was not grabbing by the legs this
crocodile grabbed the guy here killed
him that's not he said he'd die before
he hit the water no no no he grabbed her
by the leg Brian oh damn dragged her in
I think she probably dried or damn it
died from like drowning but yeah she'd
done drowns yeah it didn't either though
but I saw no he didn't need it but I saw
like a part of the Gator team which I
thought was interesting that you guys
might like that's one of the you need a
heavy girl
it's not going anywhere that Gator ain't
going nowhere with his arms wrapped like
that and then that big thick girl
sitting on his ass like that all I gotta
do is I can just tell from here you're
crazy if you don't think she enjoys a
black carrot
all I know is that feels good for them
it feels a little bit good for the uh
for her no no no he's not no it's
miserable for that kid I don't know they
killed the gator Bree she looks like
she'd feel good I heard it he got
euthanized but I mean yeah it seems like
kill the gator yeah I heard it was
euthanized I heard it yeah
Gator's a killer what I know what you're
gonna say you son of a [__] what else
we got she's uh oh this I thought okay
this is like just well Jenny now's your
time okay sit on the gator you're the
gator sir you just never let me work let
me let you work on this one yeah what do
you do I'm a gator sitter you you sit
Gators no I sit on Gators
so there's more rumor mill stuff but
Shawn Mendes you know he was with Camila
Cabello for a while now apparently he's
with a new girlfriend the reason why I
thought this was interesting because the
girlfriend is uh
chiropractor doctor whatever to the
Stars
51 years old in his 20s that's why
chiropractor who is that that's her
that's her she's so hot hold on she's in
the middle right there but 51 I can't
imagine her being 51. Jesus what a
diamond first of all hold on crack my
back with this yeah hold on who is Shawn
Mendes the senior Superstar [__] out I
know I'm sorry I'm terrible who's the
judge for the time
I love him if he's dating her that's
impressive I mean how could you not I'm
so funny in the in the chase I love you
I love you man love you too yeah well
yeah I had it for this oh she does uh
Bieber too she does like a bunch of
stars oh she's like a celebrity Cairo
[Music]
are you sure she's 51 yes and followed
by Rick
that makes sense
that's impressive as hell good for Shawn
Mendes
hell yeah
he played an alligator full circle did
he yeah that movie uh Lyle though
okay so this was funny we talked about
this on shop show but this is a radio
Raheem I think he's been on Rogan's
podcast as well he's like a boxing guy
he asked Logan what he said to uh Jake
before the fight this is the best it was
I love you too bro
[Laughter]
professional
that's really funny man so yeah I love
you too bro happens to us all bro
so there's this woman oh she's like that
girl with the black yeah Rachel dolezal
yeah yeah so so an Arab slash South
Asian Southeast Asian slash Latin why is
her mom got a ratter out mom was like
she's white she's the way she said it to
was kind of funny because she's an
[__]
but apparently she's doing good work I
don't know the same way exactly so it's
like it's a weird thing I don't know
this is all this is the all these
Americans who are like you know I I have
a whole joke about this [__] it's like
you just want to be part of something
and you want yeah yeah and you want to
be oppressed because you know your
country's doing really well when you
volunteer to be part of a group that's
been oppressed so her mom says
pepperoni
the mom's like this [__]
she's a shop at Hot Topic that's her
yeah ah then she went full right
there she goes you can't be lying like
this what are you at [__] cuckoo bird
oh yeah you are she said she's gonna
like talk about this eventually this
girl others give me a Netflix stock you
can't wait to hear I'm all about it
um all right so I should talk with a
accent I saw this video I looked up I
looked for interviews this is nine years
ago and this is I'll just play your clip
I'm not sure if I can put on the show
but Mom's like her name's Rachel
accused of being
beeps so you can tell she's just
completely playing this thing up
holy [__] and then also clearly White
yeah I look way more
yeah so you're crazy if she you don't
think she loves black carrots it's a
common thing I don't know I don't know
if that's what I would say what else you
gotcha you wanna do one more and uh so
Britney Spears posted another weird ass
video Michael B Jordan nappy or not I
know you don't care not not how could he
be yeah okay why would he be
okay great news is okay so last week
guys I made a dress it's really proud
diamond panel slip in the back a
girlfriend help me sew it sent me a
dress I didn't have to make myself I
think I can't believe it I'm just saying
okay now I'm so proud now I didn't even
have to make it myself why is she using
that British accent I don't know I think
she suffers from um crazy psychosis yeah
and I think there's a reason she doesn't
have our children that's such a bummer
extremely manner so I'll see I just want
you to know if I shut down my Instagram
not called
a roller coaster
what
isn't she Rich that's a poor person's
fan in the back
that isn't it
so her fans are the ones that called
cops to have to do us to you know what
do you call it uh something check it
well yeah
that's something going on in her brain
and I my my guess is like you said is
like you know she had this
conservatorship which was what it was
but you you kind of go they might have
known things we didn't know is that fair
right like you see that the dad's like
okay I'm done you guys want to make me
have to be the villain okay let her post
see what happens you see what I'm saying
do you know every Thursday she's pretend
she's British and pretend she's on a
roller coaster you also know she's a
[__] millionaire but uses that fan
from CVS [__] I mean whatever the case
there's stuff you know she has a fridge
stalked of black carrots I don't like
the way you're not being very kind no I
mean what are you gonna do she's clearly
[__] crazy we have nothing I can do
nothing you can do it's not about being
kind that is what it is it's it's it's
it's it's like [__] but if she wants
to other conservatorship she's out he
gives a [__] yeah nothing we can do
that's not that's manic that there that
is so clearly what you worry about is
you know her hurting herself so that was
from TMZ I don't know if they clipped or
that was clipped on her but it was
deleted I think so that's why I don't
know exactly there's no editing in the
world you can make her look not great no
no that looked crazy dude man Hispanic
don't be a roller coaster so this is the
last one does she not get to see her
kids or wow I don't know the details on
those so like once a month at Chuck E
cheese or some [__] damn so this is
Derek from more place more dates and uh
he posted this video someone did a deep
fake of him which I thought was
interesting and I'll just play it for
you right now
is Derek Moore plates moredates.com
today we're going to be talking about my
new testosterone increasing regimen
um so yeah every day I start off by
rubbing five milligrams of amphetamine
on my junk usually this causes a bit of
Burning uh but it goes away pretty
quickly the paper show this gives a
pretty substantial increase in free
testosterone usually after I'm fully
awake I put on my well they're basically
like normal socks but for each uh
individual toe that are pretty comfy and
yeah as far as I know based on the
glutamine endocrine heat response this
also leads to massive test gains uh what
else have I been doing oh yeah before I
forget So lately what I've been doing is
I wait until it's pretty late at night
like three or four a.m and once I see
someone crossing the street in front of
my house uh I quickly open the door
Sprint to them pick them up and then try
to see how far I can run with them to be
able to get some footing and Escape
activates the hunter-gatherer
neurological app looking in massive
salivary testosterone increases this is
awesome you recall previously I was
experimenting with things like picturing
chasing down any a small animal when I
was working out but after trying
everything I think the other method
moves the needle way more and uh that's
why it's in my daily routine sup guys
that's hilarious obviously it's like not
great as far as that but the voice the
voice sounds like it's yeah it's fluid
wow God well it's great it's a matter of
time before you know you're on the web
having sex with five guys with black
carrots hopefully it's happening right
now and that'll give you good math
listen if you have black carrots bring
them to Brea this Friday Friday two
shows one magical night Brea improval
this Friday Cal bass's fight companion
for Jon Jones big return with jelly roll
uh Will Compton and Rampage Jackson is
live on thick boy YouTube at 7 p.m
Saturday Oklahoma City breaks down
Comedy Club March 9th through the 11th
Tacoma March 23rd 25th tickets at
f-a-t-kz.com
this weekend Thursday Friday Saturday we
are almost sold out get your tickets
then I got Sony Hall kids New York New
York Manhattan uh March 11th one show
only Sony Hall get your tickets then we
got Levity Live the weekend after that
uh March 16 to the 18th all right kids
love you black hairs for the win yeah